we really could talk about this movie
for like ever we could just do a whole
podcast that I can relate you literally
could do like a four out and no other
Marvel movie what I feel like compelled
to do that you know that's that's my
point with this movie this is the first
time I'm like you could talk about like
almost everything in this movie for like
hours you know yeah it's like is this a
perfect movie no but it is distinct and
it's gripping it's a Marvel movie that
people will be discussing yeah it is a
game changer for the MCU in that way we
all feel like we've gotten used to
formula and stuff it's a game changer
hey reject nation Greg here John so we
just got back from watching infinity war
for the second time seven time boy I am
tired of the movie if you guys haven't
seen our non-spoiler review highly
recommended because we have an opening
sketch there at the beginning
tyro magnus actually just watched it and
i'm gonna just play for you guys what he
said I got the message when I was
leaving the theater opening sketches are
spent a lot of time working on and most
of the comments on our reviewer actually
about the sketch so thank you guys for
for all the loving feedback we've gotten
on it let's go through the spoiler talk
about this in a few days movies but now
most people have seen it most others are
out already let's go into this I guess
where I'd like to start off with this
discussion going over things that I
specifically was talking about or that
we were specifically talking about that
might feel differently in a second
viewing don't worry we'll go over all
the big deaths we'll go over everything
with movies like these especially big
hype culmination you know massive
crossovers it always feels to me like
the first viewing you break the spell of
the hype on the second viewing you can
catch the flow and this movie does flow
better the second time I actually really
enjoy the hell out of this movie I would
definitely say there's plenty of
elements in it that I love and there's
plenty of moments especially the first
time I watched it where I cheered even a
second time around there were times
where I'm like yeah I'm gonna clap again
right here first time I watched I said
there's a tonal shift issues I had and
pacing problems I had the second time
watching and I actually don't feel
necessarily that I think where the minor
problem occurs for me is it's an energy
issue I think this movie is kind of
divided into three parts one is Act one
of this film is longer than a typical
25-minute
act 1 act 1 in this movie is very
energetic and very bang-bang-bang and I
guess we could just kind of go through
this whole film like that the opening
scene I think is really cool and even
more effective the second time I watch
this because first time I watched it I
wasn't expecting such immediacy it picks
up right away asgaard is magically
obliterated already I love that opening
scene because there's so much they set
up within Thanos as a physical character
that is intimidating that first time
when Loki is like yeah I have the
tesseract but we have a Hulk and the
Hulk shows up I remember the first time
I watch that scene I was cheering it was
like so many theories have been made
about that scene alone and that was the
eyes right out the gate and it's a cool
fight because you're like yeah hopes
[ __ ] him up but then suddenly Thanos
just immediately overtakes him wherever
demos like let him have his fun right
away
you've never seen a character overpower
the Hulk that easily especially one who
kind of matches him in size and
appearance yeah that was the
intimidating factor right there and when
he kills Loki I thought that was an
awesome awesome set of you in the first
time it's not a big surprise because a
lot of us theorized much of my
predictions video how was were the ones
it was like I pretty sure it's gonna
happen right even said in my predictions
video it's not gonna happen like the
first 10 minutes of the movie Loki is
the guy who always comes back from the
dead Loki was Marvel's Avengers first
villain so that's really exists and he
was sent by Thanos so yeah to literally
watch the bigger fish killed the first
Avengers he land on screen as a personal
way this time that moment really
impacted me I was like oh yeah you're so
yeah
right now clever it's clever and when he
dies it's brutal he's just face to face
with him he's my cousin eyes right in
front of swords quentin tarantino's and
then heimdal dies it's not the movies
fault this scene doesn't have an effect
on me it's not the movies fault well
it's the Thor franchises fault that film
that moment does it have an effect okay
yeah he dies and it's more like man I
really wish they develop that character
more because that would have been way
more effective is the first mask oh oh I
like you to celebrate that as the movie
keeps going I like that first act
because there's so much energy and so
much bang bang bang to it yeah you're
rejoining all your characters as they
find out about this situation which
types of the intrigue and also is a
great way to bond with you know the
Avengers as they set out on this journey
that first fight though in New York I
love at first fight in New York
especially when they're inside dr.
Strange's place and the camera just
starts following them out and it one
moment where Tony's like help this woman
out yeah yeah those people in the car oh
yeah they're helping people cool oh yeah
and yours following them through the
street to find the source of all the
mayhem and when you do it's it's pretty
imposing and pretty rewarding yeah it's
very rewarding
yeah the whole fight is cool and the way
it's edited is neat when they start
dishing it out and then whatever I don't
know the name of the big spinny ship is
but then it cut and it smash cuts to
Peter and with his hair standing up yeah
great moment III in my mind I filled in
the blank with up meanwhile across town
yeah there's so much excitement and
intrigue there because when Spiderman is
flying up there and he's going after
strange on the great clips and
everything Hulk not hulking out I
appreciate because it shows how scared
Hulk is of the Black Order and Thanos
you know that's that's at least the vibe
I got it's not super developed I wonder
if they're scenes they cut out or
whatever but but yeah I mean especially
hearing you say that the first time
that's how I read at this time hole just
doesn't wanna yeah he seems like he's
scared to come out because he lost badly
yeah yeah yeah and then they even cut to
the Guardians and I love that that
little touch where it cuts to the
Karndean and the title texture says
space
that was neat let's do the meta Joe it's
a great that's a great meta joke
especially for who the guardians are all
that stuff with Thor showing up and then
the humor everyone's making fun of how
Buffy isn't calling star-lord fat all
this is moving along so smoothly and so
fast then they get division and Scarlet
Witch I'm putting that opening scene it
takes me a while to adjust at the fact
that they're actually like in love with
each other now it's when they're walking
on the street and visions is like I'm
just gonna speak from the heart just
black order members show up and then cap
shows up and all that [ __ ] is super
super duper cool it's like all the
intros are cool
whenever anybody shows up for the first
time you're like yeah and they use some
of the intros to have some cool action
sequences as well it's when they start
setting out on their very specific
missions when the energy shift happens
because there's like an hour of no
action and that's not a problem I'm not
saying that this film should have only
action scenes I'm not saying that so
much could be primarily action scenes
it's the balance of it I'm talking about
they have some cool scenes like okay
they go to nowhere the guardians and
then Gamora pretend kills Thanos like
that's a bit of an action scene or when
Spidey is on the ship and then he tells
Tony I've ever seen that movie aliens
and then they kill Emma Dima that's a
bit of an action sequence it's
gratifying it's gratifying it's got a
good plan because yeah it reveals the
spider legs which is awesome that was an
awesome moment and then even when the
Guardians first meet Tony dr. strange
and spider-man a little bit of action
sure to hearken back to the first
Avengers for me where it's like oh we're
all fighting each other yes we don't
know how to get along we don't know who
each other is exactly the thing is you
got to keep in mind the first 30 to 40
minutes is a lot of humor and a lot of
action and then was like an hour word
just gets really serious and slows it
down with sprinkles of humor here there
I think that's why the first time I
watch this I thought there was a tonal
imbalance when really it's just an
energy shift yeah that creates this
weird Oreo that is like fast and
high-stakes but still kind of fun on the
front and back-end and then the middle
end is a bit somber yes and there are
bands
scenes more it's like in the second act
you you you find yourself for the middle
I guess you'd say you find yourself
forgetting about certain characters and
they'll check back to people in your
back oh yeah because we've spent a long
time away from you that I didn't freak
yeah you were in the movie but I stopped
thinking about you
yeah and the thing is that that over the
course of both of these viewings I've
realized that the characters I met in
the first act are my favorites of the
movie anybody who came in later
especially in the middle are less
prominent less defined standout and I
don't want anything to miss communicate
here when I talk about the energy for
the second act of this film slowing down
and being more serious as 100% negative
I don't want it it's really just an
energy shift that can be hard to
readjust you because there's still
plenty of great things that occur within
that that second act I think there's
still a lot of greatness there I just
think it's the least effective part of
it there are great things and they're
rewarding moments throughout this movie
there are just certain to me there are
certain things that are hindered by the
very nature of what this movie is and
yeah it has to accomplish and how many
moving parts it needs to use because I
still feel like most of the characters
are kind of just the OneNote thing that
show up yeah well yeah cuz it's always
gonna be an issue when you have like 30
odd Avengers yeah yeah like if you gotta
have a mole I see a movie and not
everybody's gonna get like shine cap
especially was kind of problems
problematic for me there's been cap
shows up it's really cool they make
hints about where they might have been
up to yeah yeah everyone say a 5-star
hotels but I'm like well what have you
guys been up to you guys is like going
on random missions for who worked for
somebody just like look for problems
around the world if Chris Evans is last
movies Avengers for I want to know what
what they've been doing since the Civil
War
yeah like he does get a great moment one
of my favorite moments is be my friend
tree
and I mean it was cool to see him and
and they're calling this the Nomad look
like I was like oh cool like Nomad style
I'm excited for that it's not enough
time to me even a second viewing I
really feel like black panther it was
not utilized well he feels like a camp
you know when like a Marvel character
makes a cameo and someone else's
standalone movie yeah I know a Black
Panther feels like in this movie he
doesn't feel like a part of the infinity
war so much as it as a character who
appears in this movie yeah even the fact
that the room with Conda kind of didn't
have a huge effect on me in this time
because to me it kind of feels
borderline ready player one status I
know that's not an avatar of black
panther I get that but it doesn't feel
like a fully fledged to chala at the
same time yeah they work on to battle to
me I realized what the issue was of why
I didn't really feel the stakes all
times of watching is with the what Conda
battles specifically they're cutting
back forth between Wakanda and Titan
like granted there's some badass stuff
that happens in the Wakanda battle I
like the way is shot I like kind of like
the grittiness of it yeah it really
harkens to an epic style of filmmaking
yeah more like Lord of the Rings or
something like that where you're really
in the action and in the thick of it any
terms of the way it's shot and then
there's some great stuff there with
Scarlet Witch where she gets to do some
of the coolest stuff she's ever done
where she's taking those things that
come from under the ground demolishing
people that moment where Bucky and
rocket or spinning her kind of Harvey
back to Groot and Rocket at first one
yeah that was a really cool moment and
of course when Thor shows up that's the
best part of the Wakanda fight that's
the most gratifying part definitely I
know we're kind of going all over the
place here but you kind of will when you
do the spoiler talk for a movie like
this because the Thor storyline didn't
feel as dragged out to me this time
around no we're gonna get back to the
Wakanda battle in a sec the worst
storyline I didn't feel as dragged out
to me this time around my main issue
with Thor storyline as Peter Dinklage I
feel you I feel like he's a little I
mean you can expound on this but for me
he's a little flat and I just kept
getting distracted by things I think the
fact that they cast specifically Peter
Dinklage is distracting the first time
we watched it people kind of laughs we
saw us on opening night technically
because went through a van screening
then we went to an opening night
screening and the first like 30 seconds
he was on screen
people versus laughing because the thing
is a goofy I flip-flopped during the
first viewing half of me was like I
could see why you might snicker at this
and think it's silly I thought for
moments that it was kind of cool it's
like okay I like to us we know this man
is a dwarf or or a little person but you
know all they blew him up that's novel
it's distracting though because we know
him so well as the little any-any well
happy little little man actor would have
been distracting if you got some unknown
little man that would have been fine
what I think for me what what distracted
me further is is they had him do that
British accent and he just started to
look like a giant tyrion who let himself
go well yeah well even as British action
isn't 100% to Tyrion accidents it's a
little more yes well they just pitched
his voice test you can tell they made
voice-altering on him and it was one of
those things where I was like you didn't
need to do that he could have just had a
nothing yeah that's true they're not
real British people he's hanging out
with a neutron star like what accent
okay I get it like this dwarf is
supposed to be one of like a giant
mystical dwarf it's distracting because
it's Peter Dinklage and I'm so aware you
blew up Peter yeah yeah that's what
makes it funny it makes it rewarding
when when Thor's doing all all the stuff
of building the hammer and that moment
when Groot like gets to do something new
his one motivation where he's able to
take the axe and then make a hammer make
a handle handle out of it hold it
together even the second time I watched
him like that's cool yeah and then when
Thor shows up with rocket and Groot
that's a really rewarding moment so then
Thor's messing everyone up that's badass
it's awesome it's rewarding the general
thing about the Wakanda battle that
bothers me is there's a lack of buildup
to the Wakanda battle I think that goes
hand-in-hand with how they handle Black
Panthers specifically the first time you
see Black Panther what is it they're
talking about trying to get the stone
and divisions head cap goes I know a guy
or a No Place or something and everyone
everyone immediately Conda and then they
cut to you Black Panther he says you
know King stuff and then he's like the
White Wolf has waited long enough or
something like gives him a vibe
Mr because because he says where's the
battle he's like it's coming I guess the
battle is just and then the second time
you get back to a condo with black
panther like five minutes later there's
no escalation like there's a war coming
there's an army coming there's none of
that that's why that's why the
comparison that like a helms deep kind
of badass how some people have put it
that's what it wants to be it wants to
be an intern anyways you believe should
be then the way it's captured but in
terms of emotional stakes I don't really
feel it cuz it feels more like a cameo
by what Conda yeah well yeah yeah it
really does and I mean the the main crux
of so much of that sequence is just you
know you have Proxima midnight and tiny
or whatever the name is and just a bunch
of you know pretty icky looking but
still pretty faceless yeah creatures and
the blackboard is sort of ineffectual
except for ebony maw sort of in this
movie so a lot of it is like oh we got
to keep the Avengers busy I guess yeah
till Thanos finally gets their black
order never succeeds in doing anything
and thany so he shows up to finish the
job except for getting strange you know
to Titan which he does himselves
yeah he does I like the few jokes in the
Wakanda battle it wasn't like age of
Ultron where he has really right now
it's ruining the stage yeah you know
like when Scarlet Witch shows up and
does a badass thing in a Koi is like
where she been the whole time
why was she up there hey you know like
that was a really funny moment when
rocket says how much for the gun how
much for the ER moment Thor and Kapoor
talking about their beards like those
moments fit naturally well they're just
like exhausted and they have to just say
something do you one better not the time
but at the same time that's a perfectly
in they did a better job of the humor
intense situations for sure yeah I mean
I feel like some of the humor still a
little off it was weird how that one
moment went when they're all untied and
they're all plotting how they could take
down Thanos Tony gets mad at dragster
about listening and drops
like I stopped listening after you said
here's the plan or something like that I
need a plan like that that was just like
Direction come on in what why'd you
become this dumb but Tony's look just
staring cuz that look is going on for so
long yeah that was one of the few
moments in this movie that really like
grabbed me and disoriented me for a
second cuz I was like he's gonna say oh
no yeah he's just looking off right yeah
having a moment yeah but going into the
second act is where a lot of like the
gritty story stuff happens other than
like the finale surprises all that stuff
with Thanos and Gamora
I thought is pretty effective I like out
every time he has a stone he is always
using they showed to know where the
guardians yes the reality stone warping
what it really looks like right now I
know where I thought was a great moment
and I liked that he had Gamora go
through with that because it got me to
care more about their relationship with
Thanos and Gomorrah because she thinks
she kills Thanos there's a lot of gotcha
moments in here that's more of an
obvious moment or it's like obviously
this is so early in the movie yeah
obviously that's not dad but that's a
moment that serves well for a Kimora's
purpose because when she starts breaking
down you're like oh she really does view
him like a father even if she hates you
yeah there's no conflict exactly there's
still that father-daughter thing that
snow heels
[ __ ] up and weird yeah yeah I love all
the stuff where they're actually just
debating with each other and I like cave
or whatever and then he takes the
nebulous because he's trying to get
Gamora to talk about like where the soul
stone is yeah and that's one of the most
just cyber I was one of the most
beautiful images in the movie the way
they perspective nebula out yeah where
you come in you think she just suspended
and then you pan around and she's
completely deconstructed perspective
yeah cuz I think the writing of fan OSes
characters so good in this movie cuz I
read the Infinity Gauntlet comic book
Danis in the comic book is very much
like I always you know this is
that way chakras always like and when he
speaks very softly yeah yeah he's kind
of like poetic like a Shakespearean type
of villain in that way when they go to
voir mirror Red Skull is there that was
a great reveal that was cool I once
heard on a movie fight segment of which
villain should be brought back and
someone argued a camera which one it was
argued for red skull and the second they
chose that I was like absolutely should
be right because he's such a big villain
especially in the cat mythology you
should bring him back and I like that
they brought him back in kind of this
like mystical senses when he first shows
up I thought it was mistress death
because Thanos is whole storyline and
with the Infinity gonna is all about
satisfying mr. death press that that
yeah so I thought it was one like Pierce
and then you see her the boy cycle
obviously a man and like that voice
sounds familiar ends up being Red Skull
I think I should definitely point this
out because I didn't keep it in the Edit
of art non-spoiler review it was that I
thought if you watch this film on an
IMAX quality screen the effects might
look better for the most part they did
there are some moments that don't look
as good but the most part they did and
the scene when Thanos that has to kill
Gamora I found more effective the second
time because the first time I watched
you to look like a cartoon this time
around like it looks pretty real
actually I think that's an effective
moment and I really hope they keep like
Gamora gets killed and my theory based
off the way the movie ends and has this
moment with Thanos little Gamora yeah
and the fact that he kills Gamora then
he just wakes up in the water and he has
the stone and I feel like Kimora's in
the soul stone her soul is contained
yeah and until he gives it up or
something then you have to go through
world and rescue witty Jackie what's
become of my power I think more a dime
was clever because I don't think anyone
expected that or was particularly
surprised it's the only surprise death
really because no one was predicting
that that she would die I think the
lackluster effect for me on it is she
didn't really get it
chance to truly shine I thought she got
one of the more juicy like character
performances for this movie and in that
way it was gratifying to me because I
thought Zoe Saldana did a great yeah
like she's one of the performances it
stands out she gets dramatic wait yeah
in in film and the first time I mean
this but none of the gomorian isms that
we love yeah she doesn't give a kick-ass
or even you know like she's pretty much
100% seriously yeah she's very dramatic
and it's all about her relationship with
that and that's arguably the most
important thing you should focus on it
and which is what they do I felt like it
would have been that much more effective
if we got to have moments of just loving
her yeah yeah yeah and I mean that's
that's kind of an unfortunate byproduct
or just how much they have yeah in this
movie and yeah I could have used
something like that to rekindle all yeah
I have as far as dream said that you
have my favorite characters in this film
are definitely Tony Stark and dr.
strange are possibly dr. strange my
favorite in this movie especially I'm a
second viewing
I think dr. strange is my favorite
character in this my favorite characters
to watch were like Tony dr. strange
spider-man Thor and Gamora Thanos so he
get to the finale and then when they're
on Titan you know Doctor Strange does
have that moment where he's like scene
into the future and he says there's one
chance there's one one timeline where
there's always which is so that makes
sense what the ending is of why he
decides to hand over the time stone
because that probably links up to that
whatever future he was predicting it was
the only way it's clever because it's
also a character arc for Doctor Strange
I feel like very few characters in here
who the Avengers get it hard cuz ends
yeah and Doctor Strange has that moment
where Tony first say Tony and Spidey
first save him where he says if it's
between you and the kid and the time
stone you guys are gone yeah and then he
chooses to save Tony instead but does he
do that because he cares or does he do
that because it's part of the only
timeline in which that's the question
that's the question yeah that's a quite
a few like most you bow probably think
is because that's the way it works out
but I also got the impression that he
does care yeah I think the fight on
Titan is actually even though it's not
as she
as Wakanda I think it's a way better
file it's a more emotionally at stake
it's more heavy at stake because I love
that when he shows up it's just
Santos and Doctor Strange Thanos is you
know doing his old step the finger time
I love all that talk I love like pretty
much all the dialogue Thanos gets in
here when they're fighting Thanos I
think that fight is more rewarding
because everyone is working together in
a way where they all have to use their
specialty that was the unique part even
even Drax gets to do something that's
not just a joke you know he gets a slash
is like kaffir back of the light or
something yeah you know they all figure
in in their own unique way and Doctor
Strange is constantly helping them out
with like spider-man jumping through the
magic portals and stuff for the kick I
didn't hear that the first under logic
if you were laughing yeah in that whole
fight scene I thought was amazing it was
super super impressive and then when
they all have Thanos that's a really
intense dramatic moment it's the one
fight come on man just gets to do a
thing like oh yes yeah and the star-lord
moment is so debatable for me of what he
does next
when star-lord is confronting him about
like where's Gamora where's Maura finds
that Gamora dies and Tony's like a man
who gave your [ __ ] together we were so
close to this two sides of me occur in
that moment of yeah I get it like that's
the woman you love and you already
almost had to kill her once yeah so that
makes sense to is don't shoot what is
happening and how close if you wake him
up and you don't have the gauntlet off
you all die help out of him so I'm able
to logically forgive it in that moment
when it happens is there's even another
gotcha moment where Peters slightly gets
the glove off some Pete well the car
Peter Parker hits him away I think what
just nailed it in the direction of
annoying for me is after they all lose
and Bannos vanishes with the time stone
where will comes back and goes do we
lose yeah
ah [ __ ] for us man you [ __ ] up this is
why we got it yeah you've been in this
video STUV this movie you know thanasis
I honestly don't know how some people
are responding that moment is like ya
know it's all I don't know if everyone's
like totally get it why he did it
and it's not annoying at all oh you know
for me it's kind of annoying because
there wasn't enough there wasn't enough
emotional investment in the fact that
gomorrah and quail were now like a thing
yeah cuz before there's been just a
cat-and-mouse game yeah they're just the
thing in this movie Oh felt like quote
kind of could have anticipated that
she'd be dead because he almost killed
her with the bubbles he almost kills her
you know she was saying she was shooting
for the fact that if she gets captured
she's probably dead you know
yeah the emotional moment they get to
have together is all about how it's
probably gonna cost her life this whole
situation yeah yeah be prepared for me
to die yeah it's like I get it as a dude
totally understand as a human being at
the same time it's like there's so much
more at stake than your boyish emotions
because that's the conflicting part with
a quill and for me in this movie is
everyone treats him like he's an idiot
in this movie yeah like everyone treats
him like he's an idiot he only really
gets one cool moment when he puts the
grenade whatever the bomb that lon
Thanos is back in the future dinah'll
finger and then hops in the night that
was the only cool moment quill guess he
gets a lot of funny lines or it's always
at the expense of him being an idiot
that no one respects every time he's
trying to lead no one listens every time
he's trying to pump himself up knowingly
like there's a lot of funny ass scenes
like the first scene with him and Thor
is hilarious and anytime he talks about
the Lord it's funny that was kind of the
downgrade for me in that moment that
whole fight I do find very impactful I
do love the moment when you think that
nose kills Tony I think that's a great
gotcha moment yeah I feel like some
people could get annoyed by that like
[ __ ] Marvel [ __ ] down Tony yeah
because in that moment you think it
could go any which way even if you're
being cynical
that's the effective part about fan oohs
especially as being the main characters
you just think yeah like ever the first
time I watch
when he first shows about Wakanda very
very the Scarlet Witch he was gonna kill
the first time I wash ya at very least
especially the first time when he stabs
Tony it's like we've been speculating
that he was gonna die that was the one
moment I was like here's the moment of
this movie goes big you know and really
shocks me with something even if we
thought it might have he's done so well
and I think it's a Doctor Strange
I like the one-two combo of is he giving
the time stone because it's the only way
they could win or is he doing it because
he cares about Tony could be both and I
think the reason why I'm okay with the
fact that Ironman live is for that
moment for Doctor Strange I could get
while some people could feel like Marvel
bus you know but personally I think
that's a really effective moment so when
Thanos gets to Wakanda what I love that
moment where they're all just sure like
whoever whichever Avengers are left and
they're just trying to take about one of
each stone yeah that was really cool we
all speculated that vision would
probably die in this movie I was on the
side hoping that Marvel was misleading
us so it's not a surprise that vision
dies at by any stretch
however I'll say it's very effective
when he does die both yeah like the
first time he died I cried the first
time I watched this movie I believe
their relationship I believe their love
is like their performances I thought
were the best the sad part about vision
and to me in this movie is he doesn't
get any cool Bishop to do like nah what
I did actually didn't notice that in
like two or three scenes I didn't notice
that so the second time I watched this
it's like this she gets like no cool
things to do like no vision cool things
you stabs one of the black orga guys
with his own weapon but he doesn't get
it falls down yeah gonna do any cool
vision stuff in the air yeah even I it's
been a while since I've seen age of
Ultron and I vision was like the Jesus
of that I know he's got a whole lot of
power could he use the mindset of like
blast people can he improve this
situation yeah well so a vision dies I
thought that was very effective and it's
a great mom
of like just leaning on some hope and
it's another great gotcha moment because
you're like okay whew can't complete
that glove then when he uses the time
stone that is a great it also just makes
you hate Santos that much it's a great
moment for him as a villain because it's
like it's so heart-wrenching it's he's
just spitting all over that moment it
just happen you know what I love about
it too is it's so emotionally effective
towards Scarlet Witch yeah like she
can't even have that for vision well she
knows vision has to die and at least she
could do it in the sense of sacrifice
for the greater good she can't even have
that it's said she has him get to watch
him die for nothing
yeah now she already has the feelings of
killing the one she loves like that's an
effective ass moment it's a great moment
the big thing all right save the big
thing for the ending Thor shows up
another great gotcha moment stab Stannis
and the heart you and you do for a
second think like oh we wouldn't yeah I
do this is I did not see that coming hey
one one God versus a Titan I guess see
how this could work out and I love that
he actually does snap his finger and
then does wipe out half the universe as
the guy who actually read the Infinity
Gauntlet calm book one of the rare times
I can actually say this in terms of a
relationship with a movie and reading
some source material I thought like Oh
clever cuz that happens in like the
first 30 pages of the infinity like oh
yeah he does that Waverly has the
gauntlet so I like that they included
that the other part of me was thinking
especially on a second viewing when
everyone in the theaters like
impossible when Bucky first vanishes I'm
like oh yeah yeah that's an ocean moment
but then when Panther like number two
you're like oh they're like oh this is
just this is just a plot point and park
one of and then because so some a lot of
people are reacting to this stuff like
do they really just I don't think I'm
not one shred of me it thinks at all
that they're gone it's so bad it's a
cliffhanger that's all it is it's an
effective cliffhanger and what I'll give
that whole sequence is credit to the to
the ruses and everybody moment it looks
and feels amazing
it's everything that it ought to be and
it's just the problem is the way the
movie machine works now we just know
that like you said Kevin Feige yeah it
was robbed for me of dramatic weight
even though it is a beautiful moment
it's a beautiful moment but to me it's a
cliffhanger in a giant TV show episode
I'm not once in the audience like yeah
yeah oh cool plot point now I guess the
second one will kind of focus on how
we're gonna get these guys back right
that's for another video of like my
theories and predictions of how I think
the next one will plan what surprised me
about this movie was there was a limited
amount like there's a lot of cool things
that happens there's a lot of really
cool surprise moments throughout this
thing but in terms of like prizes to me
we're all moving and did I see that
cliffhanger coming no but is it
necessarily a shock thing like I can't
believe they did this no because it's
very apparent that a man's gonna go
subatomic inside the glove and I will
add that even though I'm not in the
audience with everyone vanishing oh my
god I think it's a great cliffhanger and
the way how there is so much death in
this film they lose in this movie does
really feel true to their word of what
Marvel's been saying how this
is a conclusion in a game-changer
because it does put me in the position
of well it's the first time I'm really
fear rising about what's the next Marvel
movie gonna be like what's gonna happen
how are they gonna do is how can they
beat Thanos it's the first time where
Marvel film is really getting me that
feeling and I'm like yes it and it
provides a different mood to it doesn't
have this like triumphant ending
characters run out of things to say like
that moment is exemplary to me when when
I think it's like banner says something
and CAPTCHA sits there for a second it
goes oh god as like as much as I'm not
in this seat believing that they're all
dead I am there feeling the emotional
effectiveness of what the characters are
going through it's not the movies fault
it's not the movies no it's not the
movie that is not the movies no but I'm
feeling what the characters are going
through and hence which it affects the
way as an audience member I'm viewing
this movie so in that way I still really
respect the editing and like the ending
and you get some more film rich scenes
because of that yeah the first time I
watched this movie the way it kind of
cuts to black bothered me the first time
I watch it cuz I'm was like this is an
Avengers movie and it just ends there
no like 10 minutes to see them D like
what the my it my still kind of an issue
is what is the arc of the Avengers here
but on the second viewing oh I get it it
really is just that OSes the main
character because the movie starts off
with Thanos he has a mission what does
he want to do he says it in the movie
collect all the stones cleanse half the
universe and then watch the Sun set in
like with a smile oh yeah and then he
does that and then it ends because
Stannis is journey MCU zone and the post
credits scene to my girlfriend brought
this up and I keep and I can't not like
she's so right and maybe you guys will
be in the combo did you how does Nick
Fury know captain Marvel's around like a
live he might know where she is but how
does he know she's not one of the people
disappearing right now you know hoping
for you know optimism open bag was the
contact captain marvel at a moment's
notice
well the other thing
and again I don't know maybe it's just
you know the way the business works now
on the way movie news works now we all
know so much stuff but even that moment
didn't hit me as much because it's like
I just I know they're shooting Captain
Marvel already yeah I've already talked
oh well captain Marvel's gonna be in the
90s but even still I mean I feel like
this moment serves to hype up the
captain like I assume that if they're
made of Captain Marvel she'll be
involved in infinity war too yeah to me
that whole like vanishing thing is a
great cliffhanger - tune in next season
who is gonna get undone and who's gonna
stay dead and they're already set photos
that revealed time travel for a part for
I think the first act and the third act
which are each like are really great
it's the second act where the only
issues I really have with the film can
actually come into play that's the only
thing that kind of prevents me from
giving this like a like a ten out of ten
that first act and third act are not
like a hundred ten minute film you know
that is a huge chunk of the movie more
than half and that stuff is all very
rewarding I still think that there's
plenty of greatness to be had there's
tons to appreciate I'm gonna steal
something from someone from Rotten
Tomatoes I don't remember who said it
but someone said this movie met my
expectations but didn't exceed them and
that's exactly when we read that I was
like that's exactly how I feel that's
exactly I feel there's no other way to
put it yeah that's I'm stealing it from
you I mean yeah that's kind of the way I
feel especially after the second one I'm
like everybody has a great moment all
yeah worlds and realms are dazzling
great fans er thanks yeah for the most
part are really great there are a lot of
great fan moments there are a lot of you
know gripping stakes and stuff but yeah
like the moments that truly surprised me
were smaller and fewer and further
between yeah a lot of things that I
expected or at least understood would be
the case given again what this movie has
to accomplish and what it needs to use
to do so anyway guys what are some
spoiler moments that we forgot to cover
for you out of this two hour and 40
minute movie you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Bell make sure to check out our opening
sketch on our non-spoiler review and
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is would love to
have you join us
you